I'm so excited to be here
I gotta tell you I've been getting asked
the same question over and over again
recently how did you make your first
dollar at the penny order well it was in
a way that was a little bit unexpected
in fact I don't know that I've ever
admitted this certainly not in front of
2,000 people but the way I made my first
dollar was through mystery shopping
here's how it worked
companies like gas stations and
restaurants would hire me to go to their
store pose undercover and then pretend
to be a customer and see how clean the
store was how nice the associates were
and then I go home and I'd write a
report about it and then I would get
paid anywhere from ten to thirty dollars
but when I was done I wrote another
report on this site here this is one of
the original versions of the penny
hoarder and I would write about how much
money I made I'm actually really
embarrassed to show this to you not
because it looks awful but I'm
remembering now that that logo I think
came from the Microsoft clip art gallery
and I think they're the sponsor please
don't sue me I know it sounds gonna get
mckee but mystery shopping was a big
part of the penny hoarder and I wasn't
just a mystery shopper but I was a beer
Auditor I got paid to pass flyers around
neighborhoods for a penny apiece I stood
on the side of the road with signs and
waved them for $8 an hour I was doing
anything I could and that's because I
was in a lot of debt like a lot of debt
like $50,000 in debt at the ripe age of
23 and much of it was student loan debt
but I hadn't been to class in years and
I certainly didn't have a degree to show
for it I found that debt to be
so very shameful I would often hide my
phone when I was around friends and
family because I didn't want them to see
the collectors calling all day long when
things got really bad I would sneak into
a hotel to steal free banana from a
continental breakfast it was a dark time
and because I was so embarrassed about I
did the only thing I could think of
which was to start writing about it
first on a free blogspot account I would
share how much debt I have what I was
doing to pay it off and through three
years of mystery shopping and penny
hoarding and beer auditing I paid that
debt off and along the way something
kind of special happened on the blog I
started to hear from readers who would
say thanks for sharing your story they
would cheer me on they would share their
own story about paying off debt and I
realized I wasn't the only one feeling
all that shame when it came to our debt
in the last couple of years the pending
order is now scaled into a personal
finance brand that reaches millions of
people I'm proud to say that in the last
couple of years
Inc 500 is ranked as the growing private
media company two years in a row and in
the last couple of months we opened a
new headquarters in st. Petersburg and I
hired my hundred employee
it's been a crazy crazy ride and I know
that sounds like a lot of easy success
but what I want to talk to you today
about is all the challenges and
difficulties that came along the way I
want to be honest with you I was
terrified to hire my first employee
absolutely terrified I was 28 a complete
introvert I still am so introverted that
I refuse to go to social gatherings in a
car pool because I want to make sure I
can sneak out the back and so the idea
of working with people every day and
having to put clothes on and not work in
my pajamas who was absolutely terrifying
and for a long time I thought I was the
only one but I've met enough
entrepreneurs now to know that there are
many introverts who here prefers to work
at home in their pajamas by themselves
okay okay there's a few of us I was
absolutely terrified to hire that first
person and so I did what any stalling
procrastinating entrepreneur would do I
put an ad on Craigslist because who
wouldn't work for a college dropout who
wrote about couponing and mystery
shopping that's an app you'd answer
right in fact I was so embarrassed that
I didn't want to tell people they'd be
working out of my house so I had them
meet me at coffee shops and in the
meantime I found another way to grow the
company for years I had been working
with freelancers and one of those
freelancers owned a Content agency and I
convinced her to sell me the company and
move her for folks to st. Petersburg I
know what you're thinking that sounds
even more scary acquiring a company but
for me it was less scary because these
are folks I knew I trusted them and more
importantly I knew I would enjoy working
with them every day we eventually did
hire and when I think back to some of
those early hires
there's a few things oops there's a few
things that we all had in common one
those early employees they all have they
all were all willing to teach me and it
can be extremely difficult to admit this
as an entrepreneur but I knew absolutely
nothing still don't and these folks were
willing to come in and teach me
everything that they knew and be very
humble about it the second thing that I
that those early employees all had in
common was they were all willing to
adapt and change very quickly one of my
Craigslist's employees as I call her was
came on board is our bookkeeper but
within a few weeks I asked her to take
on benefits and then a few weeks later
she became our HR rep and then she
became our office manager and our
receptionist and on more than one
occasion I asked her to play my personal
assistant she took on a lot of roles and
I think she's probably had about ten
titles in the last three years but
that's what you need with those early
employees because the company you're
building today is most certainly not the
company you're going to have tomorrow
people who can adapt and change with you
the last thing that those early
employees all had was that they were
early believers nobody believed that the
penny hoarder could be a thing I
remember telling my parents so I'm gonna
quit my job and I'm gonna work on a blog
called the penny hoarder
I think my mom would have preferred it
if I said I was gonna deal drugs that's
how bad that that came across but these
people believe they quit they quit their
real jobs and came and answered my
Craigslist ad met me at a coffee shop
they were crazy enough to do all of
those things and that's important
because those believers are the people
who are gonna convince the next group of
people to come join your company and
they're definitely the people who are
gonna get you through the hard times and
believe me there have been some hard
times around the end of 2015 we had
about 20 employees
and this is probably the toughest time I
had at the company I was playing a lot
of roles one of my Jobs was to write the
email newsletter every day I was just
focused on getting the product out the
door we moved into a new office but
nothing went as planned
there were termites servers went down
one of our big advertisers left us
Johnny hated Sally Sally definitely
hated Johnny yellow yelled at him in the
middle of the workroom everything went
wrong and I was working all the time I
was hustling and I would go home after
working 18 hours and I would pour myself
a glass of wine
have a quick cry just sleep for a couple
of hours and then come back and do it
all over again it's hard I think back to
that time now though and so many of the
decisions we make made back then are why
we have a culture of transparency today
I certainly wasn't telling my employees
every fear I had can you imagine
I just finished crying but I'm ready for
our meeting now don't worry but I was
open with them about how little I knew
and I'm terrified I was to run a company
I didn't have all the answers and
ironically I come to find out that they
didn't expect me to have all the answers
what they wanted was a vision they
wanted to know where we were going but
they were willing to help me figure out
how we were gonna get there they also
wanted to know that I cared and of
course I deeply cared one of the ways
that I try to show that I care is
through our benefits from the very
beginning we've given our employees
unlimited sick time paid parental leave
we've paid a hundred percent of premiums
for health insurance for both them and
their families all right and that's
something I want you to take away is
that if you can hire great believers big
believers you believe in what you're
doing and then treat them really well
they will help you figure out all the
things in between yeah absolutely
and they have helped me figure out quite
a bit as you hear me talk about my
employees I think you can tell I think
about them like family and so one of the
hardest moments I've had as a CEO is
having to say goodbye to one of them
it's something every entrepreneur goes
through at some point and we we talk a
lot about how important retention rates
are at startups and they are important
finding good people and holding on to
them is absolutely important but it's
also important to say goodbye when it's
no longer working and this is a lesson
that took me a little too long to learn
so I want to encourage you to learn it
now because what I've come to find out
is that when you do finally make that
decision it's better for the company
it's better for the team and in almost
every case it's better for the person as
well if you're just shouldn't know more
about this I highly recommend radical
candor by Kim Scott has helped me on
numerous occasions get through those
difficult periods I'll fast forward to
2017 we now have 80 employees and we're
humming like we're humming along we've
built processes we've got a plan for
onboarding new employees we've got a
plan for off-boarding we've got a plan
for how to get you on slack and how to
make sure you're ready to go on day one
we've got a plan to make sure our
Sprint's run on time and we have hired a
ton of people and we're making a lot of
money but of course it's not that easy
and of course right around 80 employees
it started to feel heavy like things
started to take a long time when we were
small the five of us could sit around my
kitchen table and all make a decision
together
remember we had a little bit bigger 30
40 50 employees us three executives
could make decisions
just by slacking each other but at 80
people there was thousands of decisions
to be made content was taking too long
to get on the site we were pursuing IT
projects that had no plan of bringing us
money or engagement in the long run and
so we blew it up we said what got us
here is not gonna get us to the next
place we formed an employee led
committee and they went through every
tool we were using which was over 50
third-party tools and came to decisions
about which ones would make sense for us
to scale to tomorrow we've reorganized
the company people change managers in a
way that allowed decisions to get made
at the department level we formed a
steering committee so that it wasn't me
deciding what IT projects were gonna go
forward but the staff and we started
over or at least that's how it felt and
I gotta tell ya
starting over is is not easy in fact it
was pretty darn stressful people
wondered well I still have a job who
will I report to what will I do all day
will this company survive but it's in
that moment that those early believers
those people who were really good at
adapting and changing started to rear
their head and say we can get through
this we can do it we've done it before
and that's gonna happen we know the
systems that we're building now for a
hundred employees will probably have to
start over again at 200 and again at 500
and again at a thousand employees so
what I want you to take away today is to
know that it's okay it's a change course
it's okay to start over again
that's part of it I've also found in the
last couple of years that I've had to
change myself as well in fact the job I
have
is nothing like the job I had three
years ago as I mentioned my job was to
get the email newsletter out the door
and you get three Twitter posts up that
day and the second year I had to think
about things like infrastructure how
would I attract and retain employees how
would I where would that where would we
all work
what would our office look like and the
third year I got to figure out how to
run a company through a hurricane that's
something they don't tell you in the
handbook it's a joy of a being of
Florida CEO and now in the fourth year
my job is a little bit more about
thinking about long term strategy and
developing leaders so that we have a
company that can be around 20 30 40
years from now I have to change myself
and that's terrifying most days I'm
doing something I've never done before
this week I got to meet with TV agents
in LA I got to review drone footage from
one of our photographers I've got to
become an expert in trademark law that
one wasn't so fun I dealt with a fire
code violation at work I never know what
the week might bring it's also the most
terrifying part worried about whether
I'll be able to keep up my own growth
with the growth of the company will I be
able to meet the company's needs and so
I think about you know when that voice
comes in the back your head the one that
says you can't do this you're not a real
CEO don't let them find out you don't
know what you're doing
when that voice comes up and it comes up
all the time no matter how far or how
many accomplishments we have I try to
think back on the last three years about
what we have gotten through the servers
being down the Hurricanes being down
finding good people paying them really
well and sometimes having to let them go
I think about all those things that
we've already accomplished being able to
create all those processes and then say
no none of those work again and that's
what I lean but lean on in those tough
moments being a CEO is probably one of
the toughest jobs that you can take on
but it's also probably one of the most
fun jobs you can take and if it ever
gets to be too much and it will I want
you to think about something that has
worked for me go home put on a pair of
pants you don't one with the drawstring
something real comfy pour yourself a
glass of wine have a cry if you need it
no judgment please some mariokart some
RuPaul take a deep breath
RuPaul gets me through a lot take a deep
breath and then you come in tomorrow you
believe in yourself you believe in your
team and you hustle your ass off because
this is the thing that got you here and
it is the thing that is going to get you
to where you're going thank you so much
hustle con
[Applause]